We’ve all been curious about
what other people are thinking
or feeling.
The primary curiosity
has now evolved
into the synchronization
of brainwaves using quantum
entanglement.
So you’re talking about
hacking into brains...
That’s correct.
The drama Dr. Brain is
a Sci-Fi, detective-mystery
and human drama
in which a scientist who
is innately lacking in sympathy
or empathy, but has excellent
computational ability,
unravels the mysterious events
that take place around him.
Case 37 concluded.
After the death of subject 77,
a complete transfer to
subject 37 occurred.
Through the brain scan, which I
developed to solve the
mysterious events around me,
I learn certain memories,
knowledge, and emotions
that I didn’t even know existed.
Brainwave sync, a success.
As Sewon gains the ability to
scan people’s brains,
he uses the ability to unravel
the mysterious events that
happen to his family.
Where’s Doyoon?
He’s gone.
What?
Find him.
As he looks into the mind of a
person he barely knows and see s
the memory of his own son, who
he thought was dead,
a great mystery arises.
Doyoon isn’t dead.
Trying to understand what
happened to his family is his
main driving force.
It seems clear you’re trying to
avoid suspicion.
You’re still a suspect in Junki
Lim’s murder.
He isn’t aware of his abilities
at first,
but he has exceptional memory.
Not only the memories,
but physical habits and actions
also get copied to him.
Wow!
We are telling a story about a
technology that doesn’t
currently exist,
And I think it ’s exciting that
we were able to tell such a
human story through the idea of
this high-tech,
cutting-edge technology.
There are many Sci-Fi elements,
but they are rooted in a human
drama.
I don’t think there has ever
been a drama
or movie of a similar genre.
While the series can be cold, it
is also a red-hot,
mystery human drama.